[music playing]
RON HOWARD: We began thinking
about how we would tell
the story of Albert Einstein,
and Geoffrey Rush instantly
was at the top of our list.
GIGI PRITZGER: The thing that
has been so gratifying to watch
in Geoffrey's
performance of Einstein
is the different shadings that
he brings to the character--
A lot to consider, I know.
GIGI PRITZGER: --and the
mischievous, humorous
side of Einstein without--
I know.
[laughter]
GIGI PRITZGER: --jeopardizing
the seriousness
and the weightiness
of the material.
RON HOWARD: Once we found
Geoffrey would be interested,
then the question
was, well who can we
find, who can we
match him up with,
because that had
to be remarkable.
KEN BILLER: Johnny
Flynn read for the part
and was put on tape in
London, and I looked at Ron,
and he looked at me, and we both
knew that this guy was so much
more interesting
than any other actor
that we had seen for the role.
GEOFFREY RUSH: Johnny and
I then met up in London
before the shoot started,
and he suggested,
he had a mentor at Central
School of Speech and Drama
that he went to, and he said
it would be really great to get
together and just muck around
with, you know, how do we walk,
how do we-- where's our center
of gravity, how much changes,
looking at how his
behavior manifested
pre-fame and post-fame.
--is not absolute.
JOHNNY FLYNN: How
fast are his thoughts,
what's his relationship
to the future,
to tomorrow, like how often does
he think about eating lunch?
You know, those are the sorts
of things that you think about.
And then we thought of
a series of characters.
We had a lot of
fun bringing in--
oh, there's a twinkle
of Harper Marx,
so there's a tiny bit of Charlie
Chaplin, there's a tiny bit--
these kind of quite sweet and
cheesy kind of situations,
but they were really helpful.
--blind regurgitation
and rote memorization
is not an education.
GEOFFREY RUSH: Well, I noticed
in the very early footage
in the teenage years,
he was very rebellious
and very
anti-authoritarian, hated
the German militaristic
sensibility.
I'm not a communist.
I'm an internationalist.
GEOFFREY RUSH: And was quite
outspoken and forthright,
but sometimes lacking
in confidence.
And I noticed in some
of the early footage
where Johnny would kind
of be licking his lips
and just that hadn't yet
found assurance and authority.
RON HOWARD: The work they've
done together and now
separately is
absolutely stunning.
It's remarkable to direct.
It's exciting to watch.
I think people are really going
to be entertained, fascinated,
moved, and really excited
by the performances
both the these men are doing.